that's he DeVos Secretary of Education
here in the United States she has proven
herself to be quite possibly one of the
most corrupt and inept people currently
serving in the Trump administration I
know Wilbur Wallace is a very close
second but ever since Scott Pruett left
there seems to be this race to the
bottom amongst the rest of the
administration officials the cabinet
officials to see who can just be the
worst overall human being and so far
after last week saying that she was
going to help pay for teachers guns to
arm themselves she tops it this week
with this story that's e DeVos and the
education department here in the United
States want to rewrite what rape means
for college campuses and basically put
the benefit of the doubt
with the accused and the institution
instead of the the people who report
having these crimes committed against
them I want to read this this is the
change as reported by the New York Times
that Betsy DeVos wants to make for the
guidelines governing sexual assault on
college campuses here it is these
changes reportedly include redefining
sexual misconduct for an um from
unwelcome sexual advances requests for
sexual favors and other verbal nonverbal
or physical conduct of a sexual nature
and change them to unwelcome conduct on
the basis of sex that is so severe
pervasive and objectively offensive that
it denies a person access to the
school's education program or activity
so under Betsy DeVos 'iz new plan it's
only considered rape or sexual
misconduct if it's so bad that you miss
class or that you can't go into a
certain building or that maybe you can't
go attend the football game this weekend
you have to not be allowed or be
physically unable because of the assault
or the attacker that it interferes with
your schooling or your extracurricular
activities if it doesn't meet those
criteria then yeah that's not rape Betsy
DeVos doesn't think that's rape the
Education Department at this point
doesn't think that that's rape
that's just college kids being crazy
college kids I guess right Betsy because
that's what your new policy wants to do
it would also only say that colleges and
universities they're only liable for
what happens directly on their campus
any kind of off-campus assault that took
place between students would no longer
be a matter for the college to even look
at that would have to be done by local
authorities who as we all know are just
awful when it comes to taking these
kinds of allegations seriously we have
had countless reports over the last few
years of local police departments all
over this country with just unused rape
kits they're not doing it there was one
police station in Oklahoma that actually
had a wall of shame women who would come
in to report any kind of sexual crime
against them would have their picture
taken and put put up on this wall of
shame they were already trying to deter
women from coming in and reporting these
kinds of crimes and now Betsy DeVos
essentially wants to make that the
policy of the US Department of Education
yeah you were raped but did you still
make it to class on time I mean cuz if
you did was it really rape you know were
you denied a proper education because of
this sexual misconduct probably not so
yeah I don't go ahead and get back to
your dorm you're fine don't worry about
it walk it off that's the policy of this
administration and let's not forget that
this is the policy that was born out of
the meeting that Betsy DeVos had with
that anti-feminist men's group to you
know pick their brains about what we
should do about sexual assault on
college campuses how about you ask the
victims how about you speak to more
women
how about you talk to the most
vulnerable in the society instead of the
people who continue getting let off the
hook for committing these atrocities
yeah I had mentioned earlier in the
program that there are civil lawsuits
mounting right now every day against
colleges and universities who have
either helped cover up systemic sexual
assault by a single employee places like
Penn State OSU USC is now involved in
this
there's also lawsuits against colleges
and universities for ignoring individual
instances by their own students Betsy
DeVos with her new little decree here is
opening up these universities for a
world of financial pain at the hands of
trial lawyers trying to get justice for
the victims here that is what is going
to happen as a result of this now I have
no sympathy for the colleges if they're
saying like yeah hey we like Betsy's
plan we don't like to have to deal with
this horrible thing called rape all the
time but it's a reality and you're gonna
get popped for it eventually you may
think that these new rules are gonna
make things a little bit easier on you
and you don't have to take it as
seriously but in the eyes of the law the
law itself it's still a crime and if you
don't take it seriously regardless of
what the Department of Education has to
say you're going to find yourself on the
wrong end of a multi-million dollar
lawsuit that threatens to tarnish your
universities credibility and reputation
for a generation we need to take another
quick break I am fairing cousins from
Ring of Fire sitting in for David Pakman
today we'll be right back with more on
the David Pakman show
today's show is made possible in part by
news voice calm / hackman we have talked
on this program for a year after year
after year how american media is
controlled by just a small handful
really of huge corporations and the
problem with having media conglomerates
among others is that you get filter
bubbles you get echo chambers and this
is something I talked about on the
program a lot there's a new media
company that's come up with an
interesting response to this problem
it's called news voice and what it is is
a website and app for both iOS and
Android which gives you a personalized
newsfeed by aggregating a mix of
mainstream media sources along with
international sources and independent
media sources importantly so any story
you look at you will get multiple
sources you can upvote stories you think
are important so that more people will
see them you can add a story to the site
you can add a source that's missing for
a particular story and the idea is for
it to be completely open and
democratized as a source of news and you
can get every side of every story check
out the app which you can download for
free if you go to news voice dot-com /
Pakman if you're watching this on
youtube simply click the link below the
video